not many new additions to a reserve team
get this sort of reception from the
phone he had to wait until the second
half even millionaire pop stars have to
earn their way into the starting lineup
once on the pit she had a few touches of
the ball his every move cheered by a
5000 strong crowd usually this type of
fixture would draw just a hundred there
were shouts as he was tackled but relief
there was no repeat of the injury he
suffered in a charity match last year I
just had to get fit first because a few
people saw happen at the other game
where bongaon doubled me and that was a
bit of a mere really so I try and avoid
that the final score was nil nil but a
smile and a wave confirmed he'd enjoyed
every minute it's absolutely amazing I
was just thinking you know those boys
gets do that every week and it really is
such a such an honor to be involved in a
club that you know I spent most of my
childhood going down to the games and
just pulling the shirt on his chest you
know by a dream some diehard
directioners had waited here in
doncaster for 10 hours and Louie didn't
disappoint
he smells like the fans left delighted
rarely has there been such excitement at
the end of a goalless draw but he
Johnson Stein use Doncaster